right
left
oh um you like can't even blame me first
because I'm literally you guys any of my
friends any of my family I am notorious
for being bad of my left and right
he's playing games
can you stand back behind your vehicle
please
just stand behind your vehicle so I was
going to the robbery with the rest of
you guys
um
two cars turned from Northbound on
Seven Springs McMullen Booth they were
north of me so I made I was stopped at
the like getting ready to make a right
turn so they turn in front of me it was
a Mustang I thought it was a Mustang in
front of behind this car I was in the
left-hand Lane
um really didn't see any driving it
until the Mustang
turned got in front of me then passed
this car and got back in the right hand
lane and when that happened we were
coming up to brain Ranch she almost
sideswiped me and I'm like oh and then
so I pulled up the cider to take a look
in them and she wouldn't look she just
kept looking at the uh Straight Ahead
then all of a sudden we went from 35 40
miles an hour to 75. she took off she
to avoid the Mustang she drove up by
this uh
storage facility drove up on the grassy
shoulder and then of course the Mustang
cook-off so I said were you following
the Mustang she said it's kind of sorta
so she's she has a valid license comes
back to I'm assuming her father the car
she said she's coming from an AAA
meeting
and
she's coming to her sister's house who
lives off of Wainwright I'm not sure if
Wayne Wright's here
um
blood bloodshot classy eye slurred
speech a note of an alcoholic beverage
so I asked her to give me her driver's
license she gave me her AAA card
um I asked her for a registration she
bends over to the glove box takes a
um envelope wipe envelope out of the and
it's soaking wet so I said did you throw
a drink in there and she says no I said
have you been drinking she says no
said have you had anything to drink she
said no as far as alcohol
and I said okay
um ask her to stay in the car she's
gotten out a couple times I heard her
rummaging for something
her on the passenger front seat her
purse looked like it was dumped out so
that's where
hello okay hi hi I'm Deputy Farrow
what's going on tonight
I literally came over my boyfriend's
birthday party I wanted to tell my
sister
I was she was so mad at me because I
didn't text her back throughout the
whole party and so I told her I will
literally come to your Purdue episode
where I was bawling my eyes out because
she didn't believe me and she was so mad
at me but she also suffers from like
bipolar disorder so I was like I'm going
to prove to you I'm sober in a way but I
was so upset about it I'm so sorry
okay so you didn't have anything to
drink tonight no sir
oh keep your head straight just follow
with your eyes okay
remember what I told you the first time
right because you you originally told me
you didn't have anything to drink then
you said you had two white claws right I
told you I know I know I know listen
like I told you honesty is the best
policy right now okay so I need you to
be completely honest with you because I
can already tell that you're lying still
four
five six
seven eight nine
and then this foot do the three-point
turn width
sorry
[Applause]
six
seven eight
nine all right
[Applause]
nope that's okay all right we're gonna
do a couple more okay you ready all
right you can begin
[Music]
one thousand twenty one thousand twenty
one without completely 1023
1024.
all right I can redo it that's okay no
that's okay
that's all right
right
left right
left
oh
um you really can't even blame me first
because I'm literally you guys any of my
friends any of my family I am notorious
for being bad of my left and right like
they'll ask me to do navigation I'm
always pick last to do it because I am
very bad about it okay
f-t-h-i-j-k Elemento p q r s t u v
no way
stop
yeah so my next question for you okay is
are you willing to give a breath sample
sure perfect
I gotta put this on you okay
all right gonna put your your shoes on
yeah we're gonna go do the breath test
oh
grow up with the situation
no no let's get your dad's phone number
so he can come and get your car and
you're not in that much more control
passenger side
take a seat probably in the labor garage
the other night
yeah yeah
okay so vegan I'm biomedical so I
understand okay Mara you can't smoke or
anything okay
positive for methamphetamines
have you had anything to drink at all no
you got a drink right there in your
center console I used to do soccer swim
and try you work at Guild nightclub I'm
adult hostess
there we go
four
five eight six
seven
one one thousand two three four just a
little bit yeah just like that okay
that's okay no you don't put your leg
down
hi there Mara how's it going yeah
what's going on
is your driver's license yes it's cool
what are you looking for
which is in the passenger seats a big
thing that
vape pen right there Ara
let me have the Connecticut license
the one that you just like ditched okay
so go ahead and step out of the car
okay
come talk to this officer while I grab
the evidence that you just tried to
destroy
whatever
yeah
don't don't anticipate where it's going
to go okay I know you've done this
before but I need you just follow
there we go all right
you know you have something better in
your trunk
okay all right left foot on the line
right from the front of your left with
your heels touching your toes arms down
to your side
don't move from that position until I
tell you to do you understand yes when I
tell you to you're going to take a
series of nine steps walking down the
line you're going to touch Heel To Toe
in every step you're going to look down
at your feet you're going to count each
step out loud
sorry okay
okay
you're gonna candy ship out loud you're
gonna leave your arms to your side any
questions so far
what what questions
yes yes please open this one on two yeah
I'm gonna wrap it around my waist
because my legs are really really really
cold
five
I'm sorry I'm so cold
six
seven
foreign
[Music]
are you done more
okay are you are you done with the
exercise
okay you could stand up straight okay
skier you're gonna bend over put your
hands like a skier okay can you do that
for me go ahead and do that for me okay
that's okay count to 30 for me you're
gonna count to 30.
good
all right Mario you're under arrest for
driving
well your normal fact these are impaired
by chemical controlled substance
it fell on the feet Jesus
is there anything else on there no not
on her
one Dy right yeah well as far as I know
I don't know if he has anything else but
positive for methamphetamines perfect
might go pee oh we don't have anywhere
for you right now when we go to the
testing center you can go pee there
um you take me to my dorm we can't do
that it's like two seconds away I know
but we really can't do that that's why I
stopped right here because I could not
walk to my door I drank three bottles of
water at work
you're gonna have to hold
the hold of the DUI test
himself let me let me give me one second
give me one second let me go talk to you
again prone to UTIs and yeast infections
and I'm on my period right now okay so
give me a second let me go talk to them
for a second and then we'll see what we
can do
so that thing that just dropped out
where was that
that was in my pants
it was in your pants it was down my pant
leg what is it it was a nicotine device
it wasn't mine it was my friends
okay I drove her home stay right here
where my flashlight is
this way so you can get them I know I
know it's just my tampon is hurting well
I know but right in there is where we
can do something about it
foreign
what are you looking for
whatever you want your license I think
it's in your lap right there
you step out talk to me a little further
around here
all right so you said you were coming
from Soho and you're going you're going
home you said
I'm gonna drop her off all right now
you're under 21. okay how many drinks
did you have tonight I like to be honest
I've only had two okay okay how'd you
get them did the bartender give it to
you did a friend
okay just just honestly random people in
the bar coming down the street uh
there's a swan uh westbound I go to turn
on on Howard see the Park South Island
how are no lights okay make the U-turn
as I'm turning around catching up to it
and she's straddling the the two lane
lines that she's coming through yeah
she's coming from going Southbound okay
uh activate my lights right here she I
think she was actually going to stop
foreign
speech odor back beverages on her breath
uh I would like to know what you could
do for
a schizophrenic person
uh well I can't do a whole lot but I
can't do anything
now that's a problem you can't do
anything let me ask you guys how much
have you had to drink tonight
a recipe
well can I check your eyes as part of
fields provided to make sure that you're
okay to be driving yeah what's that yeah
keep your head still just you drive yes
your ass
no keep your head still just redress
I'd rather just say no
can refuse my service and tell them what
the hell is going on
5c 789
sorry
I failed I failed the test what are you
gonna do take my ring there's one more
exercise
there's one more exercise I'd like you
to do okay do you want to do the last
exercise
okay that's all right you can relax your
legs
so what's going on right now is getting
placed on the rest for driving Under the
Influence okay
get down to booking I'm gonna ask her to
submit to a breast sample it's going to
measure the amount of alcohol
take some deep breaths
I love it
hey officers
please officers
get me some advice because I don't know
what to do
ow wow
it's funny because no cop is in here to
tell me no you shouldn't do that but
none of you guys are listening so I'm
gonna kill myself tonight
it was nice knowing you all I love all
the support and the drive that you've
given me but
I'm going to kill myself tonight I wish
that I could have continued one or onto
my career
and go further but
like I said
no one cares so
hello I'm in handcuffs back here I would
like somebody to talk to me
oh that was so funny as I thought that
even if I get handcuffed they would talk
to me foreign
ER talking
I just want to help with my mom
hey can we send dispatch dispatch units
to
no you're just I'm just kidding
the Narcan is impossible to find because
every unit in the hospital is ran out so
what if you have something to train what
do you have to trade
and then they created this whole
epilepsy of training
honestly please take me in behind hook
and behind cuffs though
who's watching us up here hello
quick
I don't even care if I'm what kind of
trouble I did I just want my mom to help
I don't care anymore
I don't care I really don't take me as
long as
okay
let's get my mom help I don't care can I
talk sure are you sure yeah
are you sure yeah
I just
I don't understand how they're
more rules for
mental illness you know what do you mean
rules it's just a hard thing to overcome
nothingness
straight
said myself
there's no way I'll be able to go home
right do what
right well I have to get bonded out you
have to stay for a minimum of eight
hours but after that you ought to go
home you're right I just want my cat
is my emotional support
I just you know what I'm probably gonna
fucking go to jail anyways so
covers me and take me to jail but okay I
just don't understand why
my mom that has been abusing
a 10 year old and a five-year-old
for since the moment she's been born
since the moment I've been born I've
been traumatized from mentally ill
mother my sister and I have been raised
from somebody who's not mentally illegal
companies
[Music]
you understand that
and then nobody hopes that I've been
fighting on my own for soaking long that
the fucking cops can call
the fact that I'm in the back of the cop
car
to get us in jail
I need to jail I'm so fucking mad
all right come on this way for me
yes
I'm good
that part
all right
what happened to your tires
I think I was just driving back from
Lansing
um you're driving back from Lansing yeah
well well I'm just I'm not letting you
know because I mean I saw you driving on
Merriman just out to Schoolcraft and I I
heard the fluttering of both the tires
flat and then you know
you pass you got onto Schoolcraft and
then you got into 96 and then this tire
absolutely got shredded no yeah yeah I
was in the middle of calling my
boyfriend okay
um for help how much have you had to
drink tonight
uh two glasses two glasses
um
what
red wine two glasses of red wine that's
the only thing you've had to drink
tonight honestly yes honestly okay yeah
so we do some sobriety tests you're
gonna pass them then huh
yeah okay all right you can toss your
jacket back on and hop out of the car
for me
you know how often do you drink
uh once a week you drink once a week
yeah okay
state representative I try not to do a
lot in Lansing
my knee hurts
okay
and turn around yep and nine more he'll
toe steps
yep
is that nine yeah okay this can work out
loud I can hear you no I'm sorry that's
okay
I do apologize
no it's okay that's fine I understand
your name
my left knee hurts so yeah let's try to
all right
are you with the are you able to put
your legs straight
or is that is that painful that is not
painful painful to put it to put it
straight like your legs straight
straight out in front of you like this
yeah
okay
um in my defense I've never balanced
that before so I just don't want it to
be in my defense but I can't
remember Mariah told you to count yeah
yeah kind of loud five Mississippi six
nope
one should be two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi all right
all right you can stop I don't want you
to fall or anything
okay
all right you've seen the car right
there all right so here's the PBT you
said you're gonna blow into okay so what
I'm gonna need you to do go ahead wrap
your lips around this tube okay and then
just blow like you're blowing into a
balloon all right
at the end of the day aren't I being
taken in
based on the based on the test
that was offered to you and as conducted
yes okay
this is so I'd like to wait I just you
like to wait what do you mean wait I
just mean I'm already gonna be taken in
so so this this this solely just seems
what you're at because if you're above a
0.35 that means we're gonna have to go
to the hospital with you because it's
alcohol poisoning and that's worrisome
okay and I know I only had one drink and
I don't want it to be used against me at
this point and I don't want you guys
this this is an admissible in court
okay this is this is this is completely
up to you sort of deal this is this is
to see where you're at
and then after to see where I'm at is
what I don't know I acknowledge that I
want to do that I just I'm just worried
that I just I don't feel like I was in
any trouble and now I'm in the back and
you're not even handcuffed right now I
know I'm just
um I'm shaking both the legal limit is
in Michigan
yeah so typically
generally speaking it's about two drinks
yeah okay so you're saying you only had
one drink no I had two drinks okay I did
and how long ago was that
um
less than an hour before I drove and I
did our two drinks so cute so this will
kind of help with Gage and see where
you're at on that level and helps
determine if you're overboard the limit
or under the lead
incriminating myself even if I was just
two drinks
down
at the end of the day
go go go go go all right you blew a .16
176.
all right 235.
well you know we've we come across
people like that all the time that say
that we'll understand
yeah usually it's a two like usually
it's a two-way street
like it's one lane this way one way that
way yeah not unfortunately not here
though
oh is that on Federal
so they actually right here they split
are you guys from this area I'm from
Florida no I'm busy what about you I'd
like I live here but I'm like race into
like the Atlanta to open area you really
have Christmas lights in here I do yeah
isn't it fun it is it's all right
Christmas lights
what's that the lights
where you guys coming from Russell
coming from off me El Camino El Camino
area yeah the restaurant all righty what
do you guys have there
tacos tacos yeah did you drink
you didn't drink
no no I'm dude I'm tired and I can smell
a little alcohol really
Margarita yeah
all right all right we're gonna step
over here
yeah what do you do I don't know where
I'm right over here
all right
together
I have bad balance of being left I'm
gonna touch toe yes heel touching your
toe oh wait I don't want you to start
yet okay yeah I'm gonna tell you once
again but I just want you to maintain
the position
oh this is weird just hold on one second
you gotta you gotta wait
just wait I just need you to maintain
the position okay I'm trying to be a
Cooperative I know I'm sorry okay right
in front of your left and hands at your
side
oh
okay again don't begin and don't start
until I tell you to do so can I okay do
I have to have him here yeah because
it's too
make sure your heels are touching your
toes
come on
all right
one two three
seven I mean
all right six six inches off the ground
hands at your side remember
yeah again yeah
okay
again parallel like this don't don't
bend your knee you can't bend your knee
so I know that tricks you don't see it
so again it's like this you keep your
feet together arms at your side foot
like this and you count one thousand one
approximately six inches you know
whatever yeah like Bend money no you
can't bend your knees gotta keep it a
straight all right one thousand one
balancing
without eight 2009 10
12.7 hours
13 14 15 16 17. remember one thousand
one one thousand two like that I have to
do a thousand yeah but you gotta turn
around for me
can I turn around for me
put your hands like you're praying we're
gonna do it again oh there's no doing it
again there's no doing it again but you
gotta turn around for me
put your hands like you're praying
easy
[Music]
I don't like this I don't like this I
don't like this
side space you're trying to get the
medical school
you'll be fine I'm not like that I swear
to God
I'm extremely student like never done
this before
I swear to God I thought it was a
one-way Street I didn't know it was two
ways
I don't like this shit it's like kinky
this ain't
it
but oh my God my whole career is over
here
all right come on
well now it's gonna be real balancing
oh that's sad
is it right here
according
to have you fish that way
I'm gonna go on your side select your
arms
you know that's for driving under the
influence of alcohol okay I'm gonna
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
double lock the handcuffs actually I'm
gonna move them around to the front Okay
I'm gonna take you back on the security
in my vehicle I gotta go over some
paperwork with you we're gonna end up at
our station and get you processed as
fast as I can or released as fast as I
can so you can go across the street to
the hospital okay hospital is right next
door to our Dale okay
nothing those are like spandex they
don't have pockets in them right your
pants
hang on I'm going to switch these around
to the front for you
because one of the other things I'm
going to need we need you to be able to
get in your phone because they said
you've got contact information for your
friend
I hope for her family so they're gonna
need some of that kind of stuff too I
guess they're asking for it they're just
at the hospital I'm going to take this
off you
um do you have somebody that can come
and pick up your dogs no
another friend or anybody like that
just the two of you here okay I didn't
know if you have any other friends or a
co-worker that you trust or anything
like that and not just anyone here okay
okay we're gonna head back to my car we
got a little bit of a walk
to go
um we'll get your person stuff out of
there you're falling all up and bring it
all back okay so we're gonna just walk
around this one we gotta go down here
I'm the one with the front lights on I'm
directly behind it
okay
I'm gonna come have a seat okay
whoever stop I need her phone out of
that
[Music]
can we find her phone I'm still on okay
if he wants to know
I've already asked him she said no
she said it's just her and her
um
hold them yeah cause I'm gonna get her
process and release quick um hopefully
in about an hour or so
yeah yeah there's nothing in it
you would check it real quick and then
I'll give her a phone
okay
okay here's your phone
your phone got your bag purse whatever
you want to call it in a jacket um we'll
take all that stuff with us if you could
get me contact info for your for your
friend for her her parents or whatever
whoever it is or whatever family member
you got info for
like give me that info and I'll pass it
on to
hang on hang on a second I gotta get
something ready
What's
um
hang on I can't see it okay
you get to keep an eye on her props I'm
gonna go give these numbers to LT
let me talk to you over here okay
so what happened
making it as fast as they were okay I
didn't realize there's a big line and I
literally just smacked into them I've
had two shots and one drink okay like
so
did this happen right here or work it
literally just happened right here like
right by the answer yeah like I was just
fix like the AC in my car is out like I
was just sweaty and I wasn't being smart
so you you were parked upstairs
somewhere I was like literally on the I
think third floor okay go ahead okay so
where were you before all this happened
I was on good bull I literally had one
drink at Goodwill in One Shot Two Shots
maybe okay uh what time did she get to
Goodwill tonight what time do I get to
go like probably like I probably got to
Northgate by like 11 30. probably got to
Goodwill at 12. okay
um what time do you start your first
drink roughly my first drink probably
like
night
okay and what time did you finish your
last one
I didn't even finish my last one it's
probably like I mean I didn't check the
time but probably like 1 20 1 30. okay
oh
right now I actually let me ask you this
what kind of drinks were they so I had a
monster
at Goodwill and then I had one fireball
shot and then I had one pickle shot at
Gypsy Turtle okay were they single shots
double shots I mean I just ordered like
regular I don't know how they pour them
but I like the same single I didn't ask
for doubleu and then that mixed drink
you know
I mean I finished half of it I'm
assuming it was a single yeah open uh
right now if you had to to write
yourself on a scale of zero to ten with
your being completely silver 10 being
the most intoxicated you've ever been in
your life before you say you are right
now probably like a five like definitely
like yeah okay so you're feeling it no I
feel yeah okay with that mind do you
think it's a good idea for you to be
driving right now I mean I definitely
thought it was okay to drive like okay
um if I were to hand you the keys to a
school bus full of kids right now would
you feel safe driving that probably not
because I am an education major okay I
like do you care like I would never okay
for any kids intoxicated ever
my new time now yep turn just like I
showed you
1001 1002 2003 2004 2005 2006 2007 1008
. keep going okay
welcome
in 2018
2019 2020 2021 2022
2024. okay you can put your foot down
uh so besides that the three drinks at
the bar tonight what else did you have
before I got off work today at like five
o'clock I had one
alert I went to the gym
and then around like 11 45
okay
based on everything that's happened
tonight okay with the crash that
happened here
um signs of intoxication I'm seeing
performance on these tests I don't think
it's safe to be driving tonight okay can
I have my friend take me home uh nope uh
so if you can place your hand behind
your back you are under arrest for DWI
right now okay
just move your hands away just a little
bit from the back
this is my girlfriend right here okay
can I drive that car because she was
driving it she got arrested out of it
and it's probably not even a safe
mechanical condition to be driving right
now okay the only thing is the bumper
okay
why I can't drive it because it's not
gonna say mechanical condition to be
operated on the road if you drive it on
the road I'm going to arrest you for
operating it in an unsafe mechanical
place
[Music]
so can I get this in the first if she
wants to release her property yes
okay so you want everything to go with
him you don't even want to take your
phone or anything like that
do you have any phone numbers
um
so you want the rest of the keys to go
with him in the first okay there are the
keys yeah let me grab the first okay
y'all have the phone charger at the pool
station uh probably uh do you have your
identity
I was fixing my hair while I was
sorry I'm really sorry I'm not even that
strong I've had two shots
yeah but but will you put my mug shot on
a t-shirt
I don't be mad at me like I'm trying to
be a teacher and my dad's bed so I don't
need to do lectured right now
[Music]
really haven't met that many people that
are excited for this
I love you
I'm sorry
hey the reason I'm stopping you you're
speeding on this road Boston yeah you're
going pretty fast you know what the
speed limit is
45.
45 man yeah you also failed to maintain
your land when I passed you yeah really
yeah you're passing it all right so did
my man I appreciate it hey whose uh
vehicle is this that's yours
I'm sorry I didn't give it to you
all right what are you doing out this
way sir what are you doing out this way
like party coming to Miami Lounge yeah
okay
you good you can hold that give me a
second all right just stay in the car
step out real quick and talk to me back
here man all right
anything to drink tonight no no alcohol
you know you know I'm I'm fine my man
you good who's riding with you yeah
who's in the car with him like that all
right so you've been drinking no so you
smell alcohol in the car really yeah
no you had anything to drink tonight
yeah but I'm fine what'd you have
what have you had to drink just beer a
couple beers well we we win today and we
use kind of celebrate what kind of beers
you're drinking
the president president
how many do you have
like three three four you feel like
you're safe to drive yeah
I mean you don't need to apologize all
of my friends seriously one of my
friends is around it so what what were
you coming here for this place is closed
no
we're going to the afterburn off the
gamma yeah I got you okay look I just
want to make sure it's safe to drive man
that's all it is hey if I am drunk I
know I know it's right you don't feel
like you're impaired in any way okay hey
well what I'm gonna do is make sure all
right hey
all right just let me talk to you for a
second huh yeah it's okay okay
is there any reason you were speeding on
this road
I had to get up to over 80 to catch up
to you hey look you know what
the light is about to like like yellow I
passed you way back towards the other
end and I'd turn around yeah that's what
I'm saying so you're moving all right
one thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five one thousand six one
thousand seven one thousand eight one
thousand nine one thousand then one
thousand
place my car put your hands behind your
back for me all right
you're under arrest me DUI
no no no stop it's good what do you say
uh
excuse me face my car hey
man listen just I need you to just be
quiet anywhere to come get you out
immediately okay okay don't say anything
else okay
okay thank you okay
um
Gwinnett County Jail starting miles one
eight four two one one eight four two
one one male
stops being recorded do you have your
license registration with Group
Insurance yes I do
all right so you guys have had some
drinks tonight I can smell it okay how
many drinks you have
I just personally had a beer a beer what
kind of beer
aapa our APA when was your last drink my
last drink was
about hour ago all right you might have
to check your eyes real quick
right you managed to have some alcohol
right I smell it I'm seeing signs of it
okay well let's do some fields of
running tests with you those are nice
earrings thank you they're swords that's
pretty cool where did you find those
it's okay some weird Chinese website
that's cool all right so hey here's what
I'm gonna have you do okay you see that
I see it right there all right thank you
cool Trucking
you're okay just breathe breathe
cop stressed me out hella I'm sorry one
two
three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
I just wanna go ahead sorry I would like
one thousand is that high enough for you
yeah two one thousand three one thousand
or one thousand five one thousand six
one thousand seven one thousand eight
one thousand nine one thousand ten One
Thousand Eleven two thousand twelve one
thousand thirteen thousand fourteen one
thousand fifteen one thousand sixteen
one thousand Seventeen one thousand oh
Steve Brad go go go go go go go go go go
go go
there we go all right we got it all
right so do you know what the legal
limit in the state of Washington is
22.
so you're a point one three one okay so
you're over that
thank you
actually okay
all right so
do you have anybody that can come get
your car that lives close by
I do
so do you have anything that you want to
go with us
all right do you need do you have your
wallet in there yeah
I'm just processing those
what time do you guys start drinking I
got off work
10 15. 10 15. we're at tapped in Moscow
okay
she can't pick me up around 10 45. okay
so she had not drank at all okay I had
three Wines in me so she was obviously
my designated driver yep
she did not drink anything until we got
here
when we got here
we went to the lumber yard got a drink
we got two tone cons one for her one for
me what's a Tom Collins
what do you think is in it uh vodka gin
and soda that's is
the farthest that I know okay
um we got Tom Collins one for her one
for me
that was around
I'd say 11 to 11 10. that was when we
got here
in between 11 and 2 A.M yeah from when
lumber yard closed
we had
that drink
and then she had one other drink that
was bought by the DJ yep
that
uh it was Long Island Long Island okay
so whatever is in the Long Island plus
whatever's in
Tom Collins okay so there's the Tom
Collins Long Island
and then
she had
what was it to finish off it was
I had a vodka
which would she have I had a whiskey
well she shared with me oh share the
whiskey exactly that's like that's like
why she shared I had a whiskey
with cranberry and she shared with me
but like it was mainly me that was
drinking all right all right so what are
you doing
just put your phone down
I'm sorry I don't know anything about
this my phone was right there I was not
allowed to be grabbed well that's why
I'm telling you it's okay you're not in
trouble well I feel like you're not in
trouble with that all right guys
well then hop out so you can get some
oxygen
and I'm gonna take you out of handcuffs
so we get inside okay
I will take you out of handcuffs okay
no go inside the lobby don't talk
all right all right Kylie come on
don't blow blow blow keep it going keep
going go go go keep going go go go
harder keep going go go get go go go go
go keep going go go go go keep going go
go go go keep going go go go go go go
[Music]
foreign
break your leg it's on me that type of
stuff makes me sad when I roll up and
people die from a census thing where
they can just call somebody
take it off and plug it in there
all right this one
[Music]
hey how you doing
Secaucus police
put your car in Park police officer
Gonzalez has been recording my body cam
okay what happened
you know where you are
yeah where are you you where by Hogan by
Hoboken you know what town you're in
you know a nine Hoboken
where's home
less away
you live in Secaucus where Secaucus do
you live
block away can you realize win a little
bit more
okay you understand what's going on
right now yes sir what happened what
home is it no you understand what's
going on though you understand why I'm
here talking to you brother what
happened uh yeah
you weren't driving
yes
you're going straight home where are you
coming from
uh Union City you come from Union City
what are you doing uh going straight
home you were just driving straight home
reason why I'm here is because you fell
asleep
no you didn't say any of that okay I
just woke you up right now
is it okay you're repeating yourself
all right
huh
two bucks away that's it two blocks away
or anything all right
okay your speech a little slurred okay
did you drink anything oh I had a couple
drinks you got a couple of drinks
okay perfect right I'm gonna ask you to
step by the car for me
your car leave your car park right just
about the car
we're gonna go over here to sidewalk
come inside
how much did you have to drink tonight
a couple what's a couple about how much
yeah two
okay why are you looking away from me
I'm talking to you all right
yes okay look towards me okay
what's a couple uh
so me too yeah
okay all right
okay
all right just gotta get the uh front
what's a couple of drinks all right two
about two yeah all right
um
you think he has any pocket for me I'm
sorry I'm asking for anything at the
time okay what are you doing
have you I guess you've done this
already in the past you have yeah
what's that I had to work for University
PD
I I never asked you that I don't know
why would you bring it up
that's funny okay but what that's what
does that have to do with uh you being
checked like this before nothing
I guess you want to take some type of
preference or something that you
mentioned that like I said you're being
recorded right now also okay okay all
right do me take your head off you're
doing a job take your head off
okay
okay I'm gonna ask you to do okay
you have any vehicle conditions you wear
glasses contacts you have a glass eye
okay look at me look at my pen okay
all right and you just follow my pen
without moving your head all right just
your eyes okay
don't move your head
look straight and just move your eyes
again look straight
okay just move your eyes
okay you had a couple of drinks huh
but how many
that you could remember
two or three two or three okay
put your head back on
okay do you have any uh physical
ailments with your legs or anything do
you have any problems wooden leg nothing
all good
okay
I'm gonna ask you to perform a series of
tests okay all right
first one is going to be
okay the nice steps to walk and turn
okay all right I'm gonna demonstrate for
you okay
now keep your hand to the side like this
okay
I'm gonna go like this Heel To Toe all
right okay you're gonna put your left
foot from the right right
one
two
three
four all the way to nine okay when you
get these nine steps you're gonna take a
series of small steps like this turn
back around same thing right foot in
front of the left okay one two three
four okay they have to touch Heel To Toe
okay you'll take nice steps forward and
nine steps back okay whenever you're
ready keep your hands to the side
okay you may begin
okay come over here come over here
all right what am I ask you to do okay
right
the one leg stand okay let's stand like
this hands to your side like this
exactly like I did with the with the
nice steps okay you're gonna hold your
foot up okay
all right like this
you're gonna say You're Gonna count one
one thousand two one thousand three one
thousand okay six inches up which equals
about about the size of a dollar bill
okay the length of a dollar bill okay
six inches off the ground like this okay
one one thousand two one thousand all
the way to Thirty I'll tell you when to
begin okay either either leg is fine
towards me towards me towards me towards
me
all right you may begin
kind of loud it's a one thousand two
thousand four thousand
five hundred thousand six thousand six
one thousand nine thousand seven
thousand okay that's fine that's fine
all right just turn around for me and
then just put your arms back like this
all right turn around real quick and
just put your arms out like that
do that for me
is that right
okay that's fine
all right
put James together like this put your
hands together
okay you're being arrested right now for
suspicions of driving under the
influence of alcohol okay
foreign